fiery feathers venomous spit and Jaws
that can Crush an SUV Jurassic world
Dominion features some of the biggest
and baddest dinos of the franchise but
only one can claim victory over the
others and it's done it more than once
hold on to your butts Gallimimus is a
long-necked egg stealer whose biggest
claim to fame is probably being named by
Young Tim in the original Jurassic Park
[Music]
Gallimimus
it's a fine dinosaur and it's
ostrich-like appearance definitely sets
it apart from its similarly sized
cousins but unfortunately that's about
all that Gallimimus has going for it it
isn't fearsome enough to get points in
the Fright category nor is it Majestic
enough to rub shoulders with sauropods
mostly because those shoulders are way
too high as the final nail in its coffin
Gallimimus barely appears in Jurassic
world dominion and provides little to
the story or the Thrills perhaps that's
just karmic justice for all the eggs
they've stolen over the years
our second from the bottom spot is
shared by two different dinos alike in
both size and importance the tiny
oviraptor and equally small Morris
intrepidus moros intrepidus's biggest
moment in Dominion is a single shot
where it's shown nibbling between the
teeth of a massive Giganotosaurus the
little guy is cute but he's used mostly
as a contrast to show how massive the
giganoto is oviraptor occupies about the
same amount of screen time stealing an
egg in the film's non-theatical prologue
and making an even less memorable Cameo
later on in a pit fight scene both
oviraptor and moros intrepidus look cool
but they don't stand up to the rest of
the dinos in the film and they're too
small to make much of an impact
literally and figuratively if both Dinos
get credits at the end of the film
they'd probably come below craft
surfaces
on paper Iguanodon is a pretty cool
dinosaur it said beefy herbivore with a
beak like snout that can move on either
two legs or four unfortunately Jurassic
world Dominion doesn't feature enough of
the creature to earn at a spot higher on
this list the Iguanodon only appears in
the film's non-theatrical prologue which
is set during the actual time of the
dinosaurs a group of them are shown
grazing as two Predators approach and
they're never heard from again if you're
an Iguanodon fan who was disappointed by
its minimal presence in Jurassic world
Dominion then you're in luck the 2000
Disney animated featured dinosaur casts
the dino in the starring role sure the
animation might be a little dated and
the film didn't get rave reviews upon
its initial release but a full
theatrical movie is more than most of
the dinos here have on their resumes
when you think of the most iconic
Jurassic Park dinosaurs the chicken
sized consignatus may not be the first
ones to come to mind but there's no
denying that these little guys belong on
that short list as well from their
horrific scene in the Lost World
Jurassic Park to their numerous other
appearances throughout the franchise
config Nathan is a scary member of the
Jurassic family they even get the better
of John Hammond himself in the original
Michael Crichton novel after Hammond
breaks his ankle attracting a large pack
of copies that prey on the injured sadly
the copies don't get to do much in
Jurassic world dominion and their most
notable appearance is during a stray
shot in the underground Malta Dino
Market still they earn a slightly higher
spot in our ranking for two reasons the
merits of their legacy in the franchise
and their unshakable status as the best
tiny Dino in the business
a much smaller cousin of the spinosaurus
Baryonyx is a long-snoted dinosaur that
can grow to a pretty impressive size the
species makes an appearance in Jurassic
world Dominion fighting in the
underground dinosaur Black Market in
Malta where it's seen battling in the
pits against a young Allosaurus while
Baryonyx doesn't have much in the way of
looks or power to rank above more
notable Predators the fact that it can
hold its own in a one-on-one is
definitely enough to bump it up at least
a few spots the malta fighting pits are
some of the most brutal examples of
human cruelty to dinosaurs shown in
Jurassic world dominion and there are a
bunch that makes Baryonyx not only a
cool dino in its own right but also an
Underdog Story that's definitely worth
rooting for maybe the one seen in Malta
eventually makes his way to the Dolomite
Sanctuary after the dinos all Escape
flying dinosaurs are cool they just are
they're basically the closest things to
dragon's Earth has ever seen sadly while
the Pteranodon is the most famous
example of a winged dinosaur its status
as the de facto King of the primordial
Skies is used served in Jurassic world
Dominion by other cooler flying
dinosaurs there are still a number of
scenes that feature the Pteranodon in
all their Glory from their bat-like
wings to their long skinny beaks and
pointy heads but when compared to how
impressive the pteranodons have been in
previous films Dominion just Falls a
little short a lesser known winged
dinosaur the dimorphodon shares the
pteranodon's place on this list for a
couple reasons while it is cool that the
dimorphodon's head looks like a raptor
or T-rex it doesn't get to do nearly
enough in the movie to justify a higher
position within the context of Jurassic
world Dominion both of these dinos serve
about the same purpose flying around and
looking cool without contributing much
to the story
science shows that a spiky dinosaur is
better than a non-spikey dinosaur almost
every time of those spiky reptiles
stegosaurus and ankylosaurus are
probably the two most famous whether you
prefer stego's vertical spines or
ankylosauruses spikes and club-like tail
these are undeniably two of the most
iconic dinos known to men it's fitting
that that ankylosaurus and stegosaurus
share a spot on this list if either
species had a notable role in Jurassic
world Dominion that would be enough to
separate them but they're both relegated
to the same fate a handful of pretty
Vista shots without any actual
appearances in the action for two less
spectacular dinos that would be a cause
for extinction but because of how great
both are in any context they still get
to stay in the middle tier of our
ranking it also helps that both species
feature in such beautiful shots which
makes their roles memorable despite the
lack of substantial screen time lots of
dinosaurs have intimidating appearances
but only one of them has a name that
means demon of the river sticks known
for its bone hard skull and its spikes
sticky molok is certainly an easy Dino
to pick out in a crowd even in the
densely packed multi-black Market full
of illegally acquired species Sigma lock
sticks out like a sore thumb while it
doesn't get to do much in Dominion this
Dino does give an intimidating stare
toward all the humans who pass by its
underground pen we can only assume that
it exacts some Vengeance during the mass
Dino Prison Break using its powerful
skull to free its prehistoric comrades
from captivity sticky molok gets some
bonus points in Jurassic world Dominion
for the hardships it endured as well for
simply being one of the coolest looking
dinosaurs on the planet
who doesn't love a sauropod these
long-necked humpbacks thick-legged
herbivores are some of the most iconic
dinosaurs ever discovered and they've
always played a major role in the
Jurassic movies naturally Majestic
they're often used to cement the
awe-inspiring nature of dinosaurs in
general as in their famous debut in the
original Jurassic Park it's
a dinosaur for number 17 on our Dino
ranking we're lumping two of the big
leaf eaters together Apatosaurus and
Brachiosaurus Apatosaurus might rank
slightly higher here since it gets a
beautiful encounter with some workers at
a lumber yard in Jurassic world Dominion
but it doesn't do enough to separate
itself from the brachio as the larger
and more vertical of the two
Brachiosaurus still cuts a more
impressive figure even if it plays a
slightly smaller role this time around
still that early snowy Apatosaurus scene
is undeniably impressive
at number 16 on our list it's our big
boy carnivore Allosaurus smaller than a
T-Rex but larger than a raptor the
Allosaurus is most people's ideal of the
prehistoric predator with big hind legs
Small Arms claws Jaws filled with pointy
teeth and a long impressive tail
Allosaurus is also the first dinosaur on
this list to have a more prominent role
in Jurassic world Dominion during the
extended action sequence in Malta and
Allosaurus and a Carnotaurus both escape
from an underground Dino Black Market
leading to a full-on brawl in the street
it's a cool moment that's enough on its
own to earn Allosaurus a ranking this
High unfortunately the Allosaurus is
held back from going any higher for one
gigantic reason the Giganotosaurus the
two dinosaurs look remarkably similar
with the giganoto even being mistaken
for a large Allosaurus at one point the
comparison makes Allosaurus look a lot
less impressive and interesting
especially given the huge role its
doppelganger plays later in the film
it's easy for a dinosaur to be
terrifying from their massive scaly body
bodies to their razor sharp teeth
instilling fear isn't something that
most species have to work at being cute
on the other hand is a much more
daunting task for a dino after all how
many carnivorous reptiles actually make
you want to snuggle there are two
species worthy of that honor in Jurassic
world Dominion the first listrosaurus is
seen in the malta Black Market she's a
cutie who basically looks like a squat
in the scaly Pig with a little bit of a
Triceratops type skull plate she starts
to snarl when all the action goes down
but it only makes her more adorable the
other dinosaur tied for this spot
microserdis is exactly what it sounds
like a small Triceratops like creature
with an adorable face while larger than
a listrosaurus microseridis also makes
the audience squeal at its cuteness
offering a brief break from all the
murderous rampaging
yeah yeah that's nice gotta go no one
has a longer head than Parasaurolophus
which counts for something in itself
this chunky largely peaceful Dino has
been used to set dressing in past films
given How Majestic the species looks
when moving in a herd that's still
largely how the Paris or all of us is
used in Jurassic world Dominion but it
gets a bit more time in the spotlight
not only is it the Dino and Owen's
introductory scene where he chases a
pack of creatures on Horseback like a
prehistoric Cowboy but it also has a
touching moment that's used to help us
sympathize with the Dinosaurs after
having a heck of a Time wrestling one of
the herbivores to a standstill Owen
manages to comment with some sweet words
and gentleness a final scene shows the
Parasaurolophus running alongside Wild
Horses helping us see them as animals
not monsters
who doesn't love a good sea monster
after prominent turns in Jurassic world
and Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom the
mosasaurus takes a step back in
importance in Dominion but not enough to
knock it too far down this list there's
simply nothing else like the most Source
from its gaping Ma and massive flippers
to the sheer Terror it inflicts every
time it shows up on screen it's a
monster of a dino that's in 20 000
leagues of its own additionally the few
scenes that the mosasaurus does get in
Jurassic world Dominion still managed to
take her breath away it kicks the film
into high gear at the very start by
attacking an innocent fishing trawler in
brutal fashion in a nice contrast it
ends the film by swimming peacefully by
some ordinary whales the land-based
dinosaurs may get more screen time
overall but there's something unique
about the ocean-based mosasaurus that's
still unmatched after menacing multiple
dinosaurs in Disney's dinosaur and
hunting human campers in the Animated
Series Jurassic world Camp Cretaceous
Carnotaurus finally gets a chance to
shine in live action when it appears in
Jurassic world Dominion the Carnotaurus
escapes from the malta Black Market
early in the film and quickly begins
laying waste to the City battling in
Allosaurus and devouring some innocent
bystanders along the way while it
technically has the same basic role as
the Allosaurus Carnotaurus gets a leg up
for two reasons first it just looks
cooler that blood red color in the horns
on its head give the Carnotaurus a top
tier intimidation Factor even when
compared to other carnivores second it
doesn't suffer from Giganotosaurus
comparisons the same way that Allosaurus
does fast vicious and just plain awesome
Carnotaurus is a fearsome predator in
its own right and it deserves the number
12 spot on our list on its best days
Triceratops easily gets a top 5 spot on
a favorite dinosaur list it's got the
look The toughness and the Celebrity
Status unfortunately for fans of the
three-horned species Triceratops doesn't
get much real screen time in Jurassic
world Dominion the good news is that
some of the other less famous members of
the ceratopsian family finally get some
well-deserved Spotlight shown on them in
the film Claire and her Cruz have a baby
nasus ceratops a species with only the
two top horns from illegal Dino breeders
later a herd of adultness territops
return the favor by taking down the
pursuing Dino breeders allowing Claire
and her team to escape a sinuseratops
possessing just the faceplate and Rhino
licked nosehorn of the Triceratops also
shows up in the film most prominently in
the close Montage that shows how
different dinosaurs are becoming part of
Earth's modern ecosystem some of the
species are seen walking alongside a
herd of elephants across what appears to
be the African Savannah giving viewers a
nice little bit of majestic lumbering
before the credits roll the first
dinosaur to make it into our top 10 is
none other than the dread notice a
sauropod of truly Mammoth proportions
while it doesn't get as much individual
attention in Jurassic world Dominion as
the Apatosaurus it earns a higher spot
because of its impressive size the fact
that it's never appeared in all its
glory in the franchise before just makes
it scenes more significant simply put
the dreadnaughters is awe-inspiring it's
one of the first dinosaurs that Dr Alan
Grant and Dr Ellie Sadler see during
their flyover of biostin's dolomite
Mountain sanctuary and is a perfect
choice to drive home just how big and
impressive the whole operation is
introducing dreadnaughtus feels like
both a nod and an attempt to one-upping
the sauropod reveal in the first
Jurassic Park the effect is impressive
just not as magical this time around
typically pteranodons have been the
masters of the sky in the Jurassic
franchise in Jurassic world Dominion
however that title is snatched and
carried even higher into the air by the
question not only does the winged Beast
look positively gnarly with its
gargoyle-ish head and feathery clawed
body it also stars in one of the film's
most frightening moments while flying
over the Dolomite Sanctuary Kayla Owen
and Claire are thrown into a terrifying
Airborne battle when a quetzaquatulas
chooses their airplane for an evening
snack the creature tears The Vessel to
pieces in record time forcing Claire's
to eject and Kayla and Owen to attempt a
dangerous Crash Landing everyone ends up
Surviving but it's still a heart
pounding ordeal that gives this flying
dinosaur a top spot on this list
biostin's Dolomite dinosaur Sanctuary is
home to a number of more obscure species
who've never been seen before in the
franchise one of these is the dimetrodon
a creature that precedes most proper
dinosaurs and who provides a heavy scare
to Alan Grant Ellie Sadler and Maisie
Lockwood in the film while escaping from
biosyn's facility the trio comes across
a dimetrodon in the tunnels and it very
nearly brings their journey to an abrupt
and violent end Ramsey and Ian Malcolm
saved them in the nick of time but it's
still pretty close being the star of
such a big action scene is enough to net
dimetrodon a high spot on this list but
the species is boosted even higher by
its Unique Look adequately described as
a massive alligator with the back fan of
a Spinosaurus it's an imposing creature
that you definitely wouldn't want to run
into in a dark tunnel the Donald
thesaurus occupies a very unique space
in the world of Jurassic Park despite
its small size it's one of the most
feared dinosaurs in the Jurassic Park
franchise largely because of the way it
blinds Dennis nedri with its venom in
the first film before attacking him
nedri is a pretty reprehensible villain
and the desire to see him get what's
coming to him is satisfied when he comes
face to face with a diloph source from
the dial office sources neck Frills to
the terrifying goop at spews to its
horse call this species is extremely
memorable all of those characteristics
are present when the creature returns in
Jurassic world Dominion to exact another
batch of poetic justice when Louis
Dotson the biosin CEO who originally
commissioned nejri to steal embryos from
the first Jurassic Park tries to escape
his own Fallen Kingdom he comes face to
face with a group of dinos and just like
the man he once hired dodgson meets his
gruesome end at the claws of the
dilophosaurus it's a nice full circle
moment that earns the dino a top spot on
this list
after being the de facto dinosaur
protagonist of the prior two films blue
with the Velociraptor takes a surprising
back seat in Jurassic world Dominion she
has a decent amount of screen time at
the beginning of the film but she
doesn't join in in any of the action
later perhaps the filmmakers figured
that people were sick of Velociraptors
always being the smartest and most
dangerous dinosaurs in the room making
blue decide to take a long overdue
vacation
clever girl
regardless the Velociraptor is a species
still earns the number seven spot on
this list because of Blue's child beta
while undeniably still a threat beta is
more cute than scary and the little Dino
has plenty of Great Moments throughout
the film from learning how to hunt from
its Mama to escaping the biosense
Laboratories with Maisie beta shows us a
different side of the Velociraptors that
feels fresh and entertaining and did we
mention how cute beta is despite being
the big bad of Jurassic world Dominion
the Giganotosaurus barely squeezes its
way into our top five before we get to
what's holding it back let's focus on
what's great about this dinosaur a
larger Predator than even the
Tyrannosaurus Rex Giganotosaurus
definitely has some wow factor due to
its sheer size it also has a number of
exciting moments from its Showdown with
the humans where Ian Malcolm throws a
flaming spear in its mouth to its duel
with the T-Rex in the movie's climax it
absolutely accomplishes what a Jurassic
villain Dino needs to do look big and
scary and trash everything bigger why do
they always have to go bigger
unfortunately that's also the problem
with the Giganotosaurus for all of the
build up that it receives it doesn't
really do anything that we haven't
already seen in the franchise it's as if
the writers took some of the T-Rex's
best scenes from all the past films and
just swapped in a slightly larger less
famous dinosaur as a result even
giganoto's most exciting moments are
hindered by a feeling of been there done
that by the time the T-Rex shows back up
to take it on you'll probably catch
yourself cheering not because you're so
excited about the coming battle but
because the movie finally gave you the
carnivores you actually wanted to see
clocking in at number four is the
dinosaur that largely steals the
velociraptor's Thunder its cousin the
atross Raptor seen solely in the malta
sequence biosyn's purebred
atrossoraptors are some of the fastest
and most lethal dinosaurs ever seen in a
Jurassic movie The recipients of
intensive training they go after Owen
and Claire with lethal intensity leading
to a tense chase scene where the dinos
reveal they can run just as fast as
motorcycles and trucks must go faster
the malta Pursuit is definitely one of
the standout moments in Jurassic world
dominion and that's mostly because of
the atrossoraptors it's also nice to see
the franchise find a way to put a new
Twist on the Timeless appeal of the
Velociraptors even if it only lasts for
a few minutes that being said the
atrossoraptor isn't the best Dominion
Dino to Bear the Raptor family name on
this list but more on that later red
feathered and wielding some truly
impressive claws their xenosaurus is one
of the most unique and interesting
dinosaurs in Jurassic world Dominion
from its quiet stalking of Claire and
the dolomites to its accidental victory
over the Giganotosaurus their
resinosaurus leaves a lasting impression
which is probably why it was featured so
heavily in the film's trailers there's
simply never been a dinosaur like the
Therizinosaurus in a Jurassic movie
before it looks looks like what Freddy
Krueger would become if he were a
prehistoric bird which is enough to make
it the stuff of nightmares then there's
the fact that it's featured in such a
prominent role during the film's final
act as fun as it is to see classic dinos
like the T-Rex and the Triceratops it's
arguably even more fun to see a
lesser-known species used in a new and
creative way that's exactly what the
Therizinosaurus delivers in Dominion
earning it the bronze medal there's so
much to love about the Pyro Raptor that
it's honestly hard to know where to
start for starters it has a rad name
that's perfectly suited to its fiery
feathers second it stars in arguably the
most exciting Dino encounter in Jurassic
world Dominion facing off against a
raptor of any sort with nothing more
than knives than a taser to defend
yourself is already a tough task but
doing it on a sheet of thin ice that's
just ridiculous the Pyro Raptor makes a
big impression with its sharp cries and
incredible speed but the fact that it
can swim makes it even cooler
sadly the Pyro raptor is a one and done
Dino it would have been cool to see him
show up later like the Therizinosaurus
but maybe that wouldn't have fit into an
already packed third act the Pyro Raptor
easily takes home the silver medal as
well as the title of best Raptor in the
entirety of Jurassic world Dominion did
you expect something different Jurassic
Park just tried many times to replace
the T-Rex as the biggest and baddest
dinosaur around suffice it to say that's
never worked out from its hulking skull
to its tiny arms and iconic Roar there's
just too much to love about the
Tyrannosaurus for it to ever be usurped
Rexy doesn't even have that much screen
time in Jurassic world Dominion yet she
dominates every second of it her
crowning moment is her climactic duel
with the Giganotosaurus an absolute
slugfest of Mammoth proportions that
decimates the surrounding area and while
the T-Rex does seem to go down for the
count at one point she gets by With a
Little Help from her friends a tiny
distraction is all she needs to get back
on her feet and deliver a brutal body
blow to her opponent knocking the
giganoto directly into the talons of the
Therizinosaurus and impaling it Rexy
Roars her trademark drawer as the world
Burns around her declaring she's still
unequivocally the queen
[Music]